jojoba Cancellara fidelity barrace
hawawa تونيا
hoboken مالكة ، أحد أفراد عائلة
السلمون الهائل في حمام فولكانا هذا ،
لوحة رائعة كوني لاهاف am 15 إلى
المدرسة وأفيفا الجزيرة.
يتدفق عبر هذا الأنبوب
حوالي ميل واحد ،
وللاحتفال بالذكرى المئوية
للحديقة ، سمحوا لمجموعات صغيرة جدًا
بالقيام بجولة من هنا ، دعني
أقدم لكم AB AB الذي سيظهر
لنا عبر النفق مرحبًا بكم في
تفكك ،
إنه حساس للغاية هنا وهو هش للغاية ،
هذا المكان رائع وأشعر
وكأنني ضيف هنا في كل مرة تكون فيها
أداة جديدة سارت على ما يرام Haley
mite مما يعني متابعي
كل هذا تم مسحه بواسطة الحمم
البركانية ثم  كانت منطقة السطح هي الجزء العلوي الذي
يتقشر
إذا كنت تستطيع أن تتخيله تقرأ
بالحرارة هنا وإذا كانت الحمم تذوب
السطح العلوي وتسبب تسلسل
هذه الجذور  السقف
في أنبوب الحمم وفوقنا عبارة عن
غابة مطيرة ،
فنحن في المنطقة التي تسمى
المدرج لأن هناك فتحة كبيرة
هنا في غياب الضوء ،
ثم يصبح هذا المكان
أسود تمامًا وهذا هو المكان الذي
نحتاج إلى الانحناء فيه و  عندما تصل إلى
الجانب الآخر ، لا تقف - فجأة
تبدو - إنها مثل مجموعة هوليود ، لذا
في هذه المرحلة في الواقع إذا رأيت أعلاه
، فهذا أمر مدهش
لك